head coach of Purdue footballs on the
phone line right now Jeff Brohm here on
the Rich Eisen show how are you coach
Brom good afternoon I tell you what
listen that I wish it was still Saturday
night right I mean what was it like for
you coach what was it like well well now
without question it was about as
meaningful day as you can get just a lot
of things that were accomplished you
couldn't be happier prouder of your team
University the community and just
everything went right and just a lot of
things came into play but at the end of
the day boys it was a night to remember
for our football team and University and
it's something that will share us around
here long top one was it was a moment in
the game where you thought to yourself
you know despite the confidence that you
had and the scheme that you were
bringing in and the concepts that you
had downloaded to your team that you
thought that this might actually be the
chance you could beat Ohio State on that
night coach well we had a chance to kick
a field goal in and a half go up by
touchdown and we decided to you know go
for the fake and see what happened and
we got the first down we scored the next
play I knew then that was a little bit
of a dagger that going into halfback to
give us a momentum and I was I wasn't
for sure from there this team can come
back from anything but I tell you what
every time they kind of made a run we
were aggressive in our approach we hit a
couple of big runs four touchdowns and
then we had a big pass play to rondell
Moore we broke some tackles then I was
pretty convinced it was going to happen
then we made the interception at the end
so a lot of great things continue to
happen in the second half and it was a
great feeling and something that like I
said well cherish what was the first
time you laid eyes on rondell Moore
where was that well you know what I was
lucky that he attended that high school
I went to my father is a volunteer
assistant coach on the football team
that has told me about him for a long
time I knew about you know you know how
it works all those connections help sure
now this man was highly recruited had a
bunch of options and we just kind of
sold him on what we could do for him and
while he had great opportunities
elsewhere and deservedly so we knew what
we could do for him he could be a
difference maker we could build the
offense around and we could and our
opinion guarantee that he was the the
center of our offense
and I think as he got thinking about
things in the end he started to trust us
some of the others and what he was
hearing and luckily for us we won him
over and from day one he's been a
difference maker and a huge plus for our
team yeah he jumped off the screen
coach jumped off the screen when I just
I had not seen him play before I'll be
very honest I was the first time I I
laid eyes on him and I'm like wow this
kids special you could tell well he's a
guy came in here from day one to
practice he's actually shown that on the
field doesn't miss a rep goes as hard as
anybody on her team we have monitors and
measure how hard some of our skill guys
go and he's off the charts higher than
anyone else on the team practice train
late to the field game day for a young
freshman but guys doing at the first
game Northwest he breaks all kinds of
records and then we're like holy cow
this guy's got it he's got the it factor
he loved all his humble hands the ball
the referee well he's been in the end
zone because he's been in there so and
his teammates really respect him so I
think this guy's a star and we're lucky
to have him and he's the guy that ever
continued to he lies and I would say we
don't go out and too much and get him in
before you can end a lot Jeff Brohm
Purdue head coach joining me here on the
Rich Eisen show and it also had a very
special feel to the night and again I
say this with the utmost respect for
Ohio State but it it just watching the
broadcast I mean the ABC crew the ESPN
on ABC crew were were we're featuring
Tyler Trent throughout and this is the
young man who had to drop out of school
as he's fighting cancer and he predicted
you guys would beat Ohio State and he
was part of the broadcast and I do
believe as we saw he went into the
locker room it was part of the postgame
celebration I wonder if you can walk us
through how you included him in your
plans well sort of the stories I met
about a year ago he's camped out before
a Michigan game the night before I was
just walking down to get a bite to eat
and there he was when I went over and
said hello to them never really told me
his story then but he was going through
cancer treatments he couldn't really
tell for sure how long that was but you
knew he's going through stuff and use
that as a crutch had a great attitude
great smile it kind of kept in contact
you know he was a big part of doing some
cancer research around here so we ran
into each other and that really wasn't
till rightful into brass you gave and
went down there a couple weeks ago to
play that I found out had taken a real
turn for the worse I missed him at our
press conference just some thoughts and
prayers out to him and then on the
flight home I saw some pictures and it
did not look good
and I was hearing even worse so we
decided to send our captain's up there
was the next day given the game ball
just to kind of let him know we're
thinking about him and praying for him
hoping for the best and as much as it
touched him our players got as much out
of it in return it was a meaningful
moment for him and then really from
there just kind of grooving the more you
know I wouldn't solve about a few days
later in for a guy that was going
throughout he actually every time I see
him he looks tremendous and then he made
the prediction and he wanted to come to
the game and it was about two weeks off
and we to be honest these know people
make it long you know he's able to show
up and he looked great again I mean as
far as the small plays great spirits
there's everything other than great
energy so we want him to be a part of it
and you know from in the locker room let
him talk or our players and now he
became now an inspiration to our team
but our university the community now
nation and I really feel like as much as
we've gotten out of it which we have a
ton because it does put things in
perspective I think the whole nation all
the love they've shown him he's grown
stronger and hopefully it makes him stay
with a little bit longer but it truly is
a great story is it is and hopefully it
has a happy ending you know and
hopefully it is something that he just
gets back on campus he gets well and and
we hope that again a night like Saturday
night is some wind beneath those wings
right there as for your team what do you
now you got Michigan State and you know
how tough knows the football team this
is I mean how do you keep this going
coach well that's the challenge and like
every great thing that happens you got
to respond and I'm not gonna lie I wish
this game was the last one of the year
if we could enjoy it but there's a lot
of work to be done and the great thing
that we tried to do always whether we
please make it a one drop that come back
and play the next game as good as we can
working for us you know we actually
started over three and had a loss at
home to Eastern Michigan so just goes to
show you how how bad we can't also do we
beat Ohio State that home the same year
so it shows you that we can play well so
we've got to continue to put in the
preparation you know how state lost our
last year two weeks later we went into
Iowa at four point six and we found a
way to beat Iowa so happened to happen
to them I think you saw Syracuse last
year beat Clemson who was number two in
the Cup they were sky high and then
after that game Syracuse lost five in a
row so you know it easily can can happen
we definitely haven't arrived by any
means that we have a lot of work to do
and this Michigan State team is really
good it's at their place and we won't
have more than our hands full well look
I know that you you know what you're
doing and you don't need any to sense
from any outside observers like myself
but one tip is make sure you find out if
they've done their arm and arm walk
through from one end of the field to the
other before you send your kids out
there to warm up be careful because they
might show up a little late well
obviously we we want to make sure we
adhere to their wishes okay everything
works out okay I just don't get you any
trouble but just these things may happen
these may have although you're welcome
although you are the only coach in the
Big Ten if maybe not all of college
football that has spent time in the XFL
so I don't know if you saw any of those
movements in the XFL back in the day for
the Orlando rage coach Brom well that
was a long time ago and I'm not gonna
lie coach the ball in play time and it
might have been the most fun I ever had
playing so I did have a good time is
that right oh it was a lot of fun that
question so I'm not gonna lie to you on
that what was fun about it well you know
it was kind of put in to be a fun team
and we had cameras on the field in the
locker room and we've had a game in the
six of our first game and there's been a
lot of events in history
in the first game they said they had
sold maracas Hall by halftime than any
event ever in that it was a rowdy wild
crowd and there was a lot of fights you
saw in the fan of stands and it was
still out of fun I'm not gonna lie what
was it like though you in the NFL coach
Brom you were the third string
quarterback if I'm not mistaken on the
Stan Humphries led San Diego Chargers
Super Bowl team correct
were you there well yes I was okay you
know the NFL of course was a lot of fun
as well now you know there I was kind of
a perennial backup you know just trying
to make the team every year right under
survived and enjoying the moment and you
know once you made the team it was great
because you made a lot of money and at
the fact if you don't do a whole lot so
there were a lot of pluses and I enjoyed
it but every year it was about just
trying to make the team but a lot of
great players a lot of great coaches and
I was fortunate enough to play on a lot
of great teams and even though I wasn't
in the game a whole lot it was a lot of
fun no I know but being there for that
experience what was it like being around
Junior say oh I'm curious to know well
no it was remarkable he was a tremendous
player person I still remember my first
play in practice one time I saw Stan
Humphries make a play action faked it to
the tailback junior sale came up in the
line of scrimmage it was there for the
run staying playing his back foot he
threw a 15 or 20 yard in cut to the
receivers and junior had already turned
around back caught the pass intercepted
and I said I've never seen that before
in my life believable so a lot of great
players yeah I covered Bo Schembechler
last season at the Michigan daily coach
and Michigan made this Rose Bowl that
year and junior seau
was on that USC team I honestly thought
there were 250 fives that well I really
there was I mean he kind of did his own
thing he played fast he blitzed he was
all over the place it was remarkable to
watch coach thanks for the time here
Congrats on the win on Saturday and good
luck down the road appreciate it okay
you got it that's Jeff Brohm former
Orlando rage quarterback the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience